many modern women today that just call
themselves a queen for existing yeah and
you give participation trophies just
based off of you having
okay
which is which is completely trash right
like and I think like you know we have a
society that panders to one gender so
much um of course it's easy to accept
your your participation trophy for being
a queen but if you were if you were a
queen and you were doing unsavory things
during the night during the street time
activity I think you deserve less
respect for me and to be considering you
within a relationship
what would you define as a queen
or what do you mean by Queen when you
say that yeah so like Queen is earned
right like if you think of like the
concept of king and queen you know
um you know it is a history within that
um I don't think a queen can be a queen
without a king I think that it is
necessary to have a king first that's
all
um and within that um when we live in a
culture of many ish I miss independent
all of this other all of these other
things that continue to put men down
um and then you meet with the
unrealistic standards of most most
modern women today there just seems to
be a complete like breakdown of society
and the things that are
um important within that so I think a
queen needs to have a king first and
foreign
[Music]
it's almost like we're brainwashed it's
almost like we've been brainwashed to
accept like the the nastiness of us of
society to say okay you're doing you're
you're you're half naked therefore I
like that and it's just so crazy and
it's so backwards that even dudes like
that like I I used to have guy friends
in my life that would feel like
empowered if their girlfriend wanted to
go out and be like half naked in the
club and to me that's just like it's so
crazy because that to me is not Queen
Behavior that's not marriageable
Material
what do you guys think do women do I
just think um you have to respond it as
a woman that's my only view on it okay
what do you think I just think if you
don't respect a woman like it has to be
like a good reason behind it and I also
think sometimes if someone doesn't
respect you you don't really care like
you know like if someone doesn't respect
you
their opinion don't back maybe even the
whole society you should care yeah you
should care everybody without their
boobies out and somebody's going to say
I don't like you because you're showing
all your front and you're gonna say I
don't care what they say because their
what their opinion don't matter that's
the problem with Society because it
doesn't care people don't care what
people think about them you should care
if you're out there and you're acting
and you're looking unladylike
and people are coming in and you're
trying to get a certain kind of man and
people are like slagging you off online
you should care tone it down I'm tired
of saying boobies boobies and butts and
fannies and everything's out there I'm
sick and tired of seeing it you also get
to choose who you follow and who you
don't follow on social media too though
so I do think like you know what's up
titties and bumps all the time of course
and as far as I'm concerned if you're
out there and like you're saying about
the question was about respect
how do you expect to get respect when
you're out there showing it you might
say oh I don't care but sooner or later
you're going to come to that age where
it's going to hit you and you're going
to care and no one ain't gonna give a
because all your fannies and
titties are out there and I say do you
know what see you on that as well it's
mostly women that will push women to do
only fans and stuff like that as well
like no girl go get that bye go get this
but your man will be like I don't want
you to do it that's why you don't listen
to women that doesn't I 100 agree one
million percent like women will push you
like go queen go do that but at the end
of the day you are losing more respect
for yourself by listening to a woman
telling you to go out and do that thing
that day wouldn't even do themselves you
know what I mean it's kind of just
pushing your morals just a little bit
back you know what I mean I can't say
much more of myself well I do why do
women push other women to do sex work
and um promiscuous activity when the
first thing that happens when a woman's
married she calls another girl
yeah no no and we get so offended by
that word as well when it's like you
don't have one minute because y'all
don't like each other
women don't like each other y'all the
meanest to each other but then get put
off on men oh men say this or do that
like we were talking to this one girl
outside in between the last show she was
talking about getting something done on
her body
and the girl body right she's like it's
already fine I'm saying telling her like
baby you ain't gotta do none of that but
it's not really they're not doing it for
me and they're doing it for other women
you know what I'm saying I don't really
think it's for the women though it's
more for the man because it's a man that
want it no no no no no no no
he was talking about this Society being
brainwashed this Society has been very
much to the point where they think that
is normal and they think that is okay
but but here's the thing I actually
agree with you I think they do do it for
the men but it's like sexual tension
it's not relationship attention so you
can kind of do a cheat code you can go
get a BBL get a nice body and you do get
more attention from men than if you're
flat right but here's the thing though
it's not no attention no no but but but
listen though but it goes so deeper
though because I know who you're talking
about and he has a great body yeah so
you got to think about how far down deep
that she is within watching the
Instagram models within watching The
Cosmopolitan magazine
doesn't look good to a man and now she
wants to enhance it to look like Betty
Boop you know honestly I think it's
because we're lazy as women we don't
want to go to the gym
I'm just saying if you want to get it
better then you go to the gym as a flat
woman
[Laughter]
it's pretty flat for the last 30 odd
years I've known you why would you want
gonna get it done because what's her
name's got it done it looks great he
must say yeah it might look good in
there but I don't want that in my bed
you know men want it to look at yeah to
um was it just to add for one night
but they will not marry it they will not
settle down with somebody with a fake or
lips the eyebrows and if they do it
ain't gonna last I think the issue might
be as well that some guy see how other
girls get treated when they get all
these things done so maybe if they get
flown out or good treatment and then
they think when they're not getting
anything they think that they should do
that and then get the attention the
other girls get when actually they're
getting that attention maybe because the
guy is kind of doing something
transactional with them in a way like if
you're flying them out you might expect
something from them yeah and then other
girls want to do that to get the same
treatment women need to be honest to
women because I saw a girl I interviewed
a young lady
and I was she had a she had her butt
down
feel I had a good old feel of it you
know and you wouldn't
accept
[Laughter]
it
is she here tonight
but when you think about because the
women are out there they don't think
about the pain you know the stuff when
they're getting their lips it goes rock
hard they have to get it cut out but I
looked at her ass and I thought have you
had your bum down she said yeah and I
said can I have a feel well he just and
I said you've got to cellulite and she
said yeah because I had the fat reduced
like taking that V and put in there now
women are going to go around they're
going to go say yeah we've had that butt
done but it was a it looked like an
orange
you know it just like a ordinary bump it
was nice to put the shape but it was all
at all said he like and I'm sure that
when women are thinking about getting
their butt down they're not thinking I'm
gonna get so you like years ago I used
to get like lip gloss that used to like
Sting your lips and make them swell a
bit now you want to go and get it
injected why can I can I comment on that
right so it's it's this illusion that is
taking place so women to your point want
to do it because of the reactions they
see they're getting from men but at the
end of the day it's so much deeper than
that because their mindset is so twisted
and warp and their value is placed in
this is what I bring to the table and
this is what I need to get and so I can
go get a quick fix if I get my body done
I can go ahead and get you know my boobs
done my buddy my booty done and my lips
done and I'm gonna be able to pull this
attention from a guy not knowing that
that is not lasting that's not the
attention that you want he's not looking
for a wife in that and so by the time
you're in that position you have to
maintain it right so you are looking at
your competition for the girl who
influenced you in the first place to get
that done because now she has become
your competition because your mindset
delusionally you wanted the attention
that she got but in turn of that she's
become your competition and now you have
to compete with her and maintain it and
go get more injections and get a little
poke of Botox over and over when instead
of working on your character and going
and getting healing and doing the
internal work that has gone long term
make you wife material you became an
objective object for him well I think
that the issue is as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible